Aber ich glaube, ah ja, da ist es da. Guck mal. Gute alte Neustadt. Jetzt ist meine Maus weg. Ey, sag mal wirklich.
Komm.
So, da ist sie wieder.
Das ist ja Wahnsinn.
Ah, gut, dann starten wir jetzt direkt, bevor jetzt wieder irgendwas kaputt geht. Wir wollen sprechen über den europäischen Fußball. Beide Männer, wir blicken heute auf die Ligue 1 mit Jakob Hafke, auf die Premier League mit Chris McCarthy, auf La Liga mit Nils Kahn und mit Christian Warnert auf die Serie A. Und los geht's. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Ich hatte kurz– also für mich spielte da auch zu früh zu sehr die Legenden-Cut. Und ich habe mich daran erinnert, war es nicht vor einem Jahr, wo er auch so ein Interview hatte, weil sein Vertrag nur nicht verlängert hat. Und da meiner Meinung nach war es auch schon sehr, ja anscheinend will keiner mit mir verlängern. Da musste ich mich halt umsehen. Also es wirkte schon auch damals ein bisschen drüber jetzt noch mehr. Deswegen ist meine Frage an dich. Glaubst du, da kann es jetzt im Winter zu einer Trennung kommen, dass dann irgendwie Saudi-Arabien das große XXL-Angebot? Krass.
Ja, denke ich schon. Also du sagst es schon richtig. Salah ist eine Legende und das werden Liverpool-Fans nicht hören wollen. Aber Salah ist auch, ja wie soll ich sagen, ein Mensch mit einem Ego und das spürt man sehr oft und sehr deutlich. Und das hat man schon bei deinem angesprochenen Interview gemerkt, als er da ja etwas gekränkt war, dass er noch keine Vertragsverlänger auf den Tisch gelegt bekommen hat. Und schon gar keine über fünf Jahre oder sonst was. Deswegen, also das Interesse aus Saudi-Arabien ist vorhanden. Habt man jetzt auch die Tage wieder gelesen. Es gab sogar Zitate aus Saudi-Arabien, die bestätigten, dass man da ihm im Fokus hat. Es gibt auch Interesse aus der MLS. Und wenn man dann sieht, wenn jetzt die Mannschaft performen sollte, und das ist jetzt ein ganz interessantes Timing, denn Salah muss nächste Woche zum Afrika Cup. Samstag wäre das letzte Mal, dass er in diesem Jahr für Liverpool spielen könnte, gegen Brighton. Und ja, wird jetzt interessant zu sehen sein, wie Liverpool ohne Salah in den nächsten Wochen performt. Und es kann sein, dass der Salah damit, je nachdem, was er möchte, einen Eigentor geschossen hat, zumindest auf seine Liverpool-Zukunft angesprochen. Und wenn ein Angebot kommt, dann würde Liverpool da wahrscheinlich auch relativ gut aus dem ganzen Schlamassel rauskommen. Man könnte das Geld reinvestieren, ein Seemannue holen, und vielleicht würde man im Endeffekt, ich weiß, wie gut Salah ist, aber Stand heute vielleicht sogar besser dastehen, wenn man jetzt vom Kollektiv spricht. Aber ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass Salah geht.
Berni, du wolltest noch was sagen?
Ich habe auch so das Gefühl, dass da jetzt, wie Chris sagt, dieser Sieg war enorm wichtig, weil die haben sich jetzt ein bisschen Zeit gekauft, und das merkst du auch. Ich glaube, Slot hat ja nach dem Spiel sowas wie gesagt, wie die Frage ist jetzt ja, ob der Spieler einen Schritt sozusagen kommunikativ wieder auf ihn oder auf den Verein hinmacht, oder ob ich als Trainer einen Schritt auf ihn hinmache. Also da sieht man ja schon, dass dieser Machtkampf, der ist ja noch bei beiden nicht ausgestanden. Es geht jetzt erst richtig los. Und ich glaube, Van Dijk hat sowas wie gesagt. Ja, Mo ist jetzt erst mal ab nächsten Sonntag im Afrika Cup, beim Afrika Cup. Also ich glaube, die sind jetzt alle erst mal froh, dass sie sich ein bisschen Zeit gekauft haben. Aber ausgestanden ist das noch lange nicht. Also ich glaube, das wird die nächsten Wochen erst noch so richtig angezündet. Und deswegen, Chris, wie du gesagt hast, bin ich voll bei dir. Extrem wichtiger Sieg. Aber um kurz aufs Sportliche. Man hat schon gesehen, jetzt neben der ganzen Thematik, also da ist bei Liverpool schon ein Spieler noch viel im Argen. Weil das war ein Spiel, das du nicht unbedingt gewinnen solltest. Sagen wir mal so. Und dementsprechend umso wichtiger ist so eine Situation. Aber da habe ich viel, also ich habe da Liverpool-logisch ganz anders in Erinnerung, als wie sie in San Siro aufgetreten sind. Also hat man schon gemerkt, das ist schon eine stark verunsicherte Mannschaft. Und so ein Thema obendrauf, wie du sagst, von so einem großen Namen, puh, das macht die Gemengelage nicht einfacher.
Genau. Deswegen ist, glaube ich, auch egal, wie man gewonnen hat. Und ich fand es aber relativ interessant. Genau. Ich fand es aber auch relativ interessant, wie man aufgetreten ist. Die erste Halbzeit war phasenweise gar nicht so schlecht, was ich da gesehen habe oder gelesen habe auch. Aber interessant war die Formation. Denn du hast eine Mittelfeldraute gespielt mit zwei Stürmern vorne drin. Und das heißt, du hast jetzt erstmals deine zwei Top-Sommerneuzugänge, also die Stürmer zumindest, so eingesetzt, wie es eigentlich zu ihren Anlagen auch passt, was ja vorher gar nicht möglich war, weil man ja mit dem Drei vorne drin gespielt hat, mit einem Salah vorne drin gespielt hat. Und womöglich ist das auch, sage ich mal, Glück im Unglück, dass man sich diese, meiner Meinung nach, suspekte Kaderplanung im Sommer jetzt im Nachhinein doch als gut erweist, weil du hast dann vielleicht, wie jetzt auf der 10, dann hast du vorne LKTK und nebendran ISAK. Könnte funktionieren, sieht zumindest auf dem Papier gut aus. Und jetzt mal angenommen, Liverpool spielt sich in diesem System die nächsten Wochen ein bisschen fest und man sieht, ah, ISAK kommt so langsam zu alter Stärke, jetzt wird immer stärker, könnte ja sein. Und dann sagt man auf einmal, ja, Moment mal, wo sollen wir jetzt da reinstellen, nachdem man vom Afrika Cup zurückkommt. Und umso leichter würde vielleicht die Entscheidung seitens Liverpool fallen, das Ganze zu beenden. Laut der Athletik ist man noch nicht so weit. Man hat eigentlich gedacht, diese Dekadierung sei temporär, dass man eigentlich mit Salah weiterhin plant. Aber wir wissen alle, wie es im Fußball laufen kann. Das kann relativ schnell gehen. Und wenn Salah da auch nicht irgendwie den Schritt Richtung Slot macht, was Christian gerade ansprach, dann könnte das ganz schnell zu Ende gehen. Ich fand die Aussage von Slot auch ziemlich gut, weil es gab noch ein Interview beim Inter-Spiel mit Clarence Seedorf, der übrigens eine tolle Arbeit als Experte macht. Das kann man sich mal anschauen. Da gibt es ein paar Artikel dazu auch. Er hat Slot generell noch die Geschichte gefragt. Und Slot sagte dann, man sagt immer, dass Menschen Fehler machen. Also sollte die erste Konsequenz sein, denkt der Mensch, dass er einen Fehler gemacht hat. Und dann hat man schon so rausgehört, Salah ist sich dessen vielleicht noch nicht so bewusst. Und die nächste Frage war dann, wenn du so eine Situation hast, von wem sollte dann die Initiative kommen, die Beziehung zu reparieren? Und auch da hat man rausgehört, die Slot eher Salah in der Bringschuld. Und wenn Salah da nicht irgendwann sich von seinem Ohren Ross bewegt und den ersten Schritt macht, könnte das, wie gesagt, relativ schnell zu Ende gehen.
Ah Gott, haben wir viele große Egos heute in der Sendung gehabt. Das ist ja wirklich wahnsinnig. Ich weiß nicht, was ihr gedacht habt, als ihr gesehen habt, Mo Salah postet ein Bild von ihm alleine im Trainingszentrum, im Kraftraum, während alle anderen gerade in Mailand sind. Ich glaube, Martin Schneider von der SZ hat dazu geschrieben, sein Troll-Game ist aber auch wirklich gut. Hat er leider recht.
Ich meine, er hat auch groß die Mittelsnummer auch angefangen mit seine Familie kommt ihn endlich mal wieder besuchen gegen Brighton. Und jetzt hat er überlegt, das abzusagen, weil er sitzt ja eh nur auf der Bank und seine Kinder sind Liverpool-Fans. Er weiß natürlich, wie er dann die Salah-Fans erwischt. Weil die werden dann auf seiner Seite sein. Aber da ist wie gesagt auch eine ganz, ganz große Portion Kalkül dabei.
Ich will das ja auch nicht kleinreden, dass das für ihn keine schöne Situation ist, ist klar. Aber du merkst manchmal bei Spielern, die irre Erfolg haben. Und das hat ja Mo Salah. Also seine Zahlen, seine Torzahlen in der Premier League bei Liverpool sind so hoch, dass ich dachte, das wären die Spiele, die hier gezeigt werden. Also nur ganz kurz 32, 22, 19, 22, 23, 19, 18, 29. Und dann kommt die 4 von jetzt. Also das ist absolut irre. Aber du merkst eben, wenn Spieler so herausragend sind in diesem Mannschaftssport, dann vergessen sie manchmal, dass sie in den Mannschaftssport spielen.
Genau.
So ist es.
Und sollte man auch nicht vergessen, ich habe mich jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen auf eingeschossen, aber es ist tatsächlich einfach meine Meinung, dass ich einfach sehr enttäuscht vom Verhalten Salahs bin. Aber natürlich eine absolute Liverpool-Legende und es wäre ja unfassbar traurig nach all seinen Verdiensten etc., dass das so enden würde. Also das wäre natürlich sowohl für Liverpool als auch für Salah selbst sehr, sehr traurig. Deswegen, aus neutraler Sicht wäre es ganz schön, wenn sich die Parteien da wieder finden würden. Aber wie gesagt, ich finde es etwas enttäuschend, wie er sich verhält.
Ich glaube, wir werden das noch mit begleiten. Liverpool ist ja so ein bisschen so ein Dauergast hier in der Ligatur. Als es gut lief, haben die Liverpool-Fans sich immer beschwert, dass wir nicht über sie gesprochen haben. Und sie haben Recht, weil jetzt, wo es schlecht läuft, reden wir die ganze Zeit über Liverpool. Es tut mir leid.
Ich wollte heute auch nicht über Liverpool reden und dann kam das Interview.
Ja, das hätte mich jetzt schon auch interessiert. So, wir gucken nochmal auf alle Ligen jetzt aber ein bisschen kürzer. Und jetzt reden wir aber mal, Nils, über ein Team, wo vielleicht auch wirklich das Team funktioniert. Bitte.
Ja, da funktioniert das Team. Da steht kein Trainer am Abgrund. Ich habe später noch einen kleinen anderen Titelvorschlag. Ja, also als ich in meiner vorletzten Rasenfunk-Folge war, da war noch Elche das Überraschungsteam. Die sind mittlerweile Tabell neunter. Das ist ja als Aufsteiger immer noch gut. Aber wenn man jetzt auf die Tabelle schaut, Platz 5, das hat ja letzte Saison zur Champions League sogar geführt, steht auf einmal RCD Espanyol, also der kleinere Club aus Barcelona, wie man nimmt, vielleicht hat er größere. Von dem her ist das da schon mal eine große Überraschung, weil die sind jetzt nicht wie zum Beispiel Elche durch einen überraschenden, verrückten Spielaufbau aufgefallen oder durch viele gute Transfers. Das ist einfach viel stabilitärer, teils vielleicht auch einfacher Fußball als Team zusammenhalten, aber auch mit viel Identifikation, wenn es so darum geht, wo in La Liga sind die meisten Teams mit viel Nachwuchs. Da fällt da natürlich der Athletik-Club aus Bilbao ein, aber nur Athletic und Osasuna haben noch mehr Eigengewächse oder weniger legionären Kader, von dem mir da steckt schon mal bei Espanyol einiges an Identität drin. Kapitän Javi Puedo ist da zu nennen, Paul Lozano generell auch viel. La Liga-Erfahrung, also man kann sagen, bei Espanyol wird Spanisch gesprochen, das wäre so ein Titelvorschlag. Und in Deutschen gibt es ja auch noch Clemens Riedel, der kam aus Darmstadt, spiel auch ab und zu, aber vielleicht so ein bisschen Star der Truppe, Trainer Manolo Gonzalez, der ist jetzt 46 schon, trainiert aber schon angeblich seit 30 Jahren, als er im Jugendalter frühe Verletzungen hatte, wie so oft sonst wäre er auch Profi geworden, da schon im Jugendbereich früh trainiert, hat sich dann lange hochgekämpft unter klassige Ligen, teilweise auch noch Busfahrer nebenbei gewesen. Ja, und jetzt mit Espanyol parkt er nicht den Bus, er nimmt alle mit rein und ist dadurch in der Volkreich mit ihm aufgestiegen. Und so ist Espanyol grad, sorgt für positive Vibes in der Liga.
Aber wirklich, und glaubst du, ist das nachhaltig? Also, ich meine, es muss jetzt nicht Rang 5 werden, aber wir freuen uns immer über Geschichten aus Spanien, wenn es mal jemand anders als die erwartbaren Teams nach oben schafft. Deswegen, so haben wir ja auch über Elche gesprochen. Wie denkst du über Espanyol?
Ja, das ist jetzt mal ein positiver Ausreißer, aber es kommt schon auch durch viel normalen, einfachen Fußball. Es sind jetzt in keiner Statistik irgendwo groß mit dabei, wenn es darum geht, Meisterabschluss, aber auch nicht die meisten Abschlüsse kassieren. Auch alles von der Aggressivität ist alles auch so auf Mittelfeldplätzen mit ihren 40, 41 Prozent Ballbesitz. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen niedriger wert, aber du merkst schon, es ist auch schon viel auf Flanken ausgelegt. Sie haben vorne einen Kike Garcia mit drin, der knips ganz gerne mal. Dann haben wir auch Pere Milla, der hat auch schon fünf Saison-Tore. Da sind so ein paar dabei, wo man merkt, Espanyol weiß, worauf es ankommt. Sie haben auch die meisten Abschlüsse, glaube ich, im 5-Meter-Raum. Es ist, wie gesagt, viele hohe, lange Bälle, was in der Liga aktuell noch funktioniert. Aber es ist trotzdem auch ein bisschen was an Momentaufnahme, weil jetzt die nächsten Spieler, sie müssen nach Etaffe, dort ist immer ein bisschen Beton, nach Bilbao. Dann kommt es zum Derby gegen Barcelona. Vielleicht haben sie jetzt auch einfach mal wieder dann drei Spiele ohne Sieg. Das wird dann trotzdem noch zu irgendwie Top Ten oder so reichen. Aber aktuell haben sie sich da so ein bisschen hochgekämpft, hatten ja auch schon früh Atletico geschlagen mit 2 zu 1, auch zuletzt bei Rio oder gegen Rio bestanden und irgendwie Celta geschlagen. Es sind auch viele positive Ergebnisse eingefahren. Sie müssen nicht mehr die Doppelbelastung. Das Problem sind sie los unter der Woche. Letzte Woche gab es das Pokal aus gegen Viertligist Atletico Baleares. War ein bisschen unglücklich. Aber da kann man sich jetzt, wie man so schön sagt, auf die Liga konzentrieren und hat da eben ein paar gute Spiele. Auch so ein Edo Exposito ist der Spieler mit den drittmeisten Schussvorlagen der Liga November. Petri können da mithalten. Meistere Flanken gibt er ab, Edo Exposito. Also ein paar spannende Namen. Nochmal Kapitän Javi Pujado mag ich sehr. Chris Romero kennen vielleicht auch einige. Von dem her wächst da gut was zusammen. Durch Aufstieg schon gar nicht so viel verändert am Kader von Manolo Gonzalez. Aber wahrscheinlich bei meinem nächsten Rasenfunk-Auftritt wird es wahrscheinlich nicht Genio. Espanol ist jetzt noch geklettert auf den Champions-League-Rang. Vielleicht geht es runter auf nur die Neuen.
Aber trotzdem, umso mehr lohnt es sich ja mal, über diese Teams zu sprechen. Und ich sage es ganz ehrlich, in einer Parallelwelt, in der die Tage mehr Stunden hätten, würde ich Clemens Riedel anfragen für ein Tribüngespräch und mal fragen, wie es da so läuft. Also sechsmal stand er an der Startelf, sieben Spieler hat er insgesamt gespielt. Manchmal war er auch nicht im Kader, aber würde mich mal schon interessieren, einfach nur die einfache Einstiegsfrage, was ist anders, was ist der Unterschied zwischen Darmstadt und Barcelona? Denn diese Frage, sie muss mal beantwortet werden.
Die Flanken sind es vielleicht nicht, die hohen Welle, aber ansonsten.
Du, wegen mir hätten wir da auch erstmal nur über die Städte reden können, aber das ist jetzt ein ganz anderes Thema. Also sehr schön, Espanyol, Barcelona. Wisst ihr, was los ist, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer? Und wir brauchen aber auch noch ein Wissen Sie, was Nizza betrifft? Jakob, vorhin habe ich Nizza schon einmal kurz erwähnt, denn sie waren Gegner von Lens. Nee, werden sie jetzt noch sein. Entschuldigung, Sorum war es. Nizza hat ein bisschen Schlagzeilen gemacht, seitdem wir das letzte Mal gesprochen haben, was ja gar nicht so lange her ist. Also gib uns ein Update, bitte.
Sie gehen mit ganz viel Rückenwind in das Duell gegen den Tabellenführer, haben nämlich jetzt wettbewerbsübergreifend 7 Spiele in Folge verloren. Allein seitdem David das in der letzten, nee, in der vorletzten Folge, glaube ich, angesprochen hat, haben sie alle Spiele logischerweise dann auch verloren. Sie haben die Serie gebrochen, für die es schlechteste Team Frankreichs in Europa, haben da seit 18 Spielen nicht gewonnen in Europa. Also wirklich unfassbare Zahlen. Davon auch nur viermal unentschieden gespielt. In dieser Spielzeit alle sieben Spiele auf europäischer Ebene verloren. Also sowohl in der Champions League-Quali als auch in der Europa League. Da sind sie Tabellenletzter mit Null Punkten. Und das ist gar nicht das Schlimmste. Das ist nämlich das Allerschönste an der Geschichte. Denn diese ganzen Sachen, die ich jetzt erzählt habe, sind eigentlich jetzt in den letzten beiden Wochen zu Nebenkriegsschauplätzen verkommen. Denn es gab vor zwei Wochen am Wochenende eine Niederlage gegen Lorient, also gegen einen der Aufsteiger. Und danach sind die Spieler dann am nächsten Tag, müsste es gewesen sein, wieder in Nizza angekommen am Trainingsgelände. Es wurden da erwartet von rund 400 Fans, Anhängern. Und die haben dann den Bus belagert und einige Spieler auch angegriffen, als diese dann aus dem Bus ausgestiegen sind. Also es war erst wohl noch relativ ruhig, als die Führungsspieler wie Melvin Bar ausgestiegen sind. Da gab es nur Diskussionen, in Anführungsstrichen. Und dann wurden aber zwei Spieler und ein verantwortlicher, Florian Maurice, der Sportdirektor, und die beiden Spieler, Tere Moffi und Jeremy Boga, wurden dann auch tätlich attackiert. Da sind die Medienberichte so ein bisschen unterschiedlich. Manche sagen auch, dass es keine wirklichen körperlichen Übergriffe geben sollte, wo ich mich dann auch so frage, ja gut, macht es das jetzt so viel besser? Was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen wirklichen körperlichen Übergriffen und nicht so wirklichen körperlichen Übergriffen? Also, ich glaube, wir sind uns da alle einig, dass alles, was in die Richtung geht, viel zu viel ist. Und Tere Moffi und Jeremy Boga haben sich dann auch erst mal krankschreiben lassen, waren jetzt auch beim letzten Spiel nicht dabei. Und ja, es ist einfach ein einziges Chaos. Es gab jetzt bei dem am letzten Spieltag, hat die Mannschaft sich hinter diese beiden Spieler gestellt, den Namen der Spieler auf den Rücken gehabt. Das ist in Frankreich tatsächlich erlaubt, dass man nicht mit dem eigenen Namen auf den Rücken spielt. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das in anderen Ligen ist. Während des Spiels? Ja, das gab es vor ein paar Wochen auch schon mal. Da hatte Lons das genutzt als Tribut an ehemalige Spieler, auch an ehemals verstorbene Spieler. Das fand ich da eine sehr schöne Aktion. Und jetzt war das gleich wieder. Der Fall ist sicherlich etwas verwirrend. Also die Nummern müssen logischerweise gleich bleiben. Die Namen scheinen irgendwie egal zu sein. Aber gut, das ist jetzt auch nicht so das Allerwichtigste. Es ist tatsächlich vielleicht nicht unbedingt Zufall, dass es Thierry Moffey und Jeremy Boga getroffen hat. Denn gegen Thi gab es besonders viel Ärger. Bei Thierry Moffey war es so, dass er nach der Niederlage gegen Lorient mit dem Präsident von Lorient am Lachen war. Und das wurde von den TV-Kameras eingefahren. Er hat vor ein paar Jahren mal in Lorient gespielt. Dementsprechend gibt es auch eine persönliche Beziehung. Erklärt es, also begründen oder erklären kann es das nicht. Es ist aber natürlich wichtig, das trotzdem zu erwähnen, weil Jeremy Boga war es schon ein paar Wochen länger her, als Nizza gegen Marseille gespielt hat. Hatte Boga wohl relativ vielen Freunden aus der eigenen Heimatstadt Karten besorgt für das Spiel. Problem, diese Freunde sind alle Marseille-Fans, weil er daherkommt aus dieser Stadt. Dementsprechend hat das dann auch nicht so gut Anklang gefunden bei den Anhängern. Aber die Wut der Fans richtet sich auch nicht nur gegen diese beiden Spieler, sondern eigentlich gegen alle. Denn der sportliche Niedergang von Nizza ist schon auch krass. Man ist zwar tatsächlich nur Zwölfter in der Liga, hatte zwischendurch mal ein kleines Zwischenhoch, was einen bevor noch davor bewahrt hat, jetzt so wirklich im Abstiegskampf zu stecken. Aber die Fans sind überhaupt nicht zufrieden mit dem Kader, mit der Spielweise. Man hat die drittschlechteste Abwehr der Liga, aber auch die Zahlen sind total schlecht. Und man hat eigentlich ganz andere Ziele. Man will um Europa mitspielen. Und das ist dann darin kumuliert, dass es jetzt am Wochenende beim Heimspiel gegen Angers noch nicht mal 8.000 Zuschauer im Stadion waren. Also die Fans haben das eigentlich komplett boykottiert, obwohl man eigentlich einen Zuschauerschnitt von weit über 20.000 hat. Und selbst das ist schon relativ gering für Nizza-Verhältnisse gewesen jetzt in dieser Saison. Also eigentlich hat man da immer sich auf wirklich guten Support auch verlassen können. Man fordert unter anderem mehr Spieler aus der eigenen Jugend. Und jetzt gegen Angers, wo man natürlich auch wieder verloren hat, wurden auch alle Spieler ausgepfiffen, eigentlich durch die Bank weg, auch dauerhaft schon beim Reinkommen auf den Platz. Es ist so ein bisschen die Frage, wo das jetzt alles hinführen soll. Überraschenderweise ist tatsächlich Frank S immer noch Trainer. Also das hatten wir, hatte ja glaube ich David auch schon spekuliert, ob das überhaupt noch der Fall sein wird. Aber er hat gesagt, er möchte bleiben, hat das aber auch mit so einem indirekten Appell zumindest an die Mannschaft verbunden und gesagt, er möchte dafür sorgen, dass alle jetzt sich zusammen raufen und zeigen, was es bedeutet für Nizza, auf dem Platz zu stehen und das Ruder sozusagen herumzureißen. Ich glaube, für den Verein ist das eigentlich ganz gut, dass man jetzt nicht vielleicht noch einen neuen Trainer suchen muss. Zumal Franck, er ist ja eigentlich in der Vergangenheit auch einer der erfolgreichsten Trainer in der Ligue 1 war in den vergangenen Jahren. Also vielleicht gelingt es ja noch unter ihm, das Ruder herumzureißen, allerdings wie jetzt genau dieser riesige Cut zwischen Fans und der Mannschaft und dem Verein wieder gekittet werden soll, bin ich mal sehr gespannt.
Also wir werden es im Blick behalten, aber 8.000 ZuschauerInnen, das ist dann schon krass. Und was es allerdings dann auch bringen soll, die Spieler schon vorher auszupfeifen, das sind so Dynamiken, die sind zwar nachvollziehbar und verständlich, wenn man selber mal emotional im Fußball involviert war, aber kannst du dich, brauchst du dich nur einmal mit Spielern unterhalten, und dann sagen die, das macht es eigentlich immer schlechter und schlimmer nochmal, denn die Spieler, egal was man ihnen unterstellt, verlieren wollen sie dann doch nicht selber. Also wir schauen uns an, was bei NHTSA noch so passiert. Vielleicht sammelt man ja irgendwann auch mal europäisch den ersten Punkt. Das ist schon wirklich…
Oder Dante kann endlich wieder spielen.
Stimmt. Ja, stimmt, richtig. Von dem habe ich auch länger nichts mehr auf Social Media gesehen. Dabei war da meine Zeit lang ganz schön präsent in meiner Timeline. Vielleicht gibt es da einen Zusammenhang. Muss ich mal nachgucken. Vielleicht liegt es auch am Algorithmus. Springen wir nochmal in die Serie A. Christian, was hast du uns noch mitgebracht?
Ein schneller Satz noch. Jeremy Boga ist ja aus Italien nach Nizza gewechselt. Und was man aus Italien so vernimmt, wird der Ende Januar nicht mehr in Frankreich sein. Also der, glaube ich, hat damit auch abgeschlossen. Und da gibt es auch anscheinend ein, zwei Interessenten in Italien. Die Fiorentina anscheinend ist womöglich so ein Name, der genannt wird. Also die betroffenen Spieler, glaube ich, hat es schon ziemlich hart getroffen. Wie ist sie das so? Quasi, ja, ich glaube, für Boga scheint das Kapitel Nizza abgeschlossen zu sein.
Schön, dass ihr dann endlich zu einem Team im Aufschwung wechseln könnt. Aber das Thema hat wir ja schon.
Genau. Ich wollte euch kurz, aktuellen Stand, nur kurz zu Napoli mitbringen. Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch, ich glaube, als wir über Bologna gesprochen hatten. Das war ja, als wir Bologna positiv beleuchtet haben. Da war dieses 2-0 von Bologna gegen Napoli vor ein paar Wochen. Und da war Napoli wirklich kaum wieder zu erkennen. Also da gab es wenig, wenig Positives. Und seitdem hat Conte aber den Turnaround geschafft. Jetzt gab es gestern dieses 0 zu 2 bei Benfica. Da war wenig zu holen. Da war auch die Energie raus. Aber in der Liga hat er sie wieder auf Kurs bekommen. Und zwar auch, indem er einen Systemwechsel vorgenommen hat. Also zur Einordnung hat man ja auch schon… Also De Bruyne fehlt ja wochenlang schon mit einer schweren Verletzung. Anguissa fehlt jetzt mehrere Monate. Lobotka war jetzt zuletzt raus oder ist immer noch raus. Also im Prinzip sein komplettes Stammmeterfeld ist ihm weggebrochen. Und deswegen ist er weg von der Viererkette und ist jetzt auf so ein 3-4-2-1 gegangen. Das gibt der defensive Stabilität. Also Beukhema und Bongiorno fühlen sich in der Viererkette wirklich sehr wohl, verteidigen gut nach vorne durch. Und mit Neres und Lang hast du jetzt zwei Kreative, die das so über außen, aber auch ein bisschen in den Hall bräumen, die haben richtig viel Tempo reingebracht. Neres seit Wochen in richtig guter Verfassung. Und das hat in der Liga dazu geführt, Napoli hat Atalanta geschlagen, Napoli hat Roma geschlagen und Napoli hat jetzt vergangenen Spieltag Juve geschlagen. Also alle großen Spiele gewonnen, sind jetzt wieder Punkte gleich mit Milan auf Platz 1. Und deswegen konnte da wirklich so ein bisschen aus einer energielosen Mannschaft die unfassbar verletzungsgeplagte Miss Lukaku fehlt ja auch schon die ganze Saison, Maret fehlt, der Nationalkeeper, Billy Gilmour im Mittelfeld auch noch. Also im Moment, nur um euch das mal zu verdeutlichen, Elmas spielt im Moment auf der 6. Also er hat so gut wie keinen zentralen Mittelfeldspieler mehr. McTominay spielt auch, spielt jedes Spiel, hat keine Pause, spielt im Prinzip auch im Moment auf der Doppel-Sechs, weil es einfach keine Alternativen mehr gibt. Und aus der schwierigen Situation hat Konter das schon, muss man sagen, da erst mal wieder Energie reingebracht. Und gestern gegen Benfica haben sie auch gesagt, die waren platt, die spielen jetzt seit drei oder vier Wochen, alle drei Tage mit dem kurzen Kader. Da war Benfica einfach zu stark, genau.
18. Dezember, ich glaube, den sollten wir uns alle merken. Da wird Napoli zu Hause gegen Milan spielen.
Ja, das ist Supercoppa.
Sollte man da die Reihe fortsetzen?
Ja, das ist Supercoppa. Ach so, ah. Da kann ja Nils auch. Die italienischen und die spanischen Supercoppa-Termine sind ja auch immer ganz, ganz spannend. Genau, ja, da geht es dann halt um einen Titel. Ich wollte es eben nur kurz reinbringen. Vielleicht auch einen Satz noch dazu. Das war in der Länderspielpause. Dann hat sich Conte für ein paar Tage aus Neapel verabschiedet und hat danach– das war logisch ein riesen Thema– oh, er lässt die Mannschaft alleine. Und da hat er gemeint, hey Jungs, kommt mal alle runter. In England zum Beispiel ist das ganz normal, dass man auch mal als Trainer ein paar freie Tage hat. Und hat sich da sozusagen wirklich aus der Stadt, ist nach Turin, hat da immer noch ein Haus, hat sich da ein bisschen zurückgezogen. Und seitdem aber ist da wieder Energie drin. Also Conte hat es schon geschafft, da irgendwie wieder mit seinen, ja, Motivationsgeschichten und so wieder Energie reinzubringen. Wie gesagt, die gehen personell wirklich im Moment auf den Krückstock. Er hat auch gemeint, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie bis Januar reinkommen. Das Gute ist, Lukaku ist jetzt wieder ins Team-Training zurückgekommen. Also es wird sicher noch Wochen dauern, bis der spielen kann. Aber das wird immer eine gute Nachricht. Und wenn er dann langsam wieder ein paar von diesen wichtigen Spielern zurückkriegt, glaube ich, wird das dann auch wieder ein bisschen anders aussehen. Aber er hat halt diesen, sage ich mal, Energiemodus wieder gefunden und Napoli da jetzt bis auf dieses Benfica-Spiel jetzt schon wieder sehr gut in die Spur gebracht.
Aber wirklich. Sehr schönes Update aus Italien. Chris, wir blicken noch mal auf die Premier League. Und wenn ich mir da die Tabelle angucke, da sehe ich auf Rang 3 hinter Arsenal und City, Aston Villa liegen. Und jetzt wirst du mir aber erzählen, warum das nun eine Momentaufnahme ist. Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Ja, richtig. Also nicht nur Platz 3, sondern auch nur 3 Punkte hinter Arsenal, muss man dazu sagen. Super Leistung gegen Arsenal am Wochenende, 2-1 gewonnen, typische MRE-Performance, hohe Intensität, gute Struktur, defensiv etc. Arsenal wirkt auch platt nach den ganzen Verletzten, das hat man gemerkt, verdient der Sieg. Und ganz interessant ist, Aston Villa hat jetzt 9 der letzten 10 Spiele gewonnen, darunter gegen Arsenal, darunter gegen City. Ebenfalls interessant, habe ich gesehen, die Heimstärke von Aston Villa. Europaweit die meisten Heimsiege in den letzten drei Jahren. Drei Jahre, das hatte ich jetzt auch nicht auf dem Zettel. Ziemlich interessant. Dabei hatte Aston Villa jetzt wirklich einen schlechten Sommer. Man hat ja so ein bisschen Financial Fair Play sorgen, dass man nicht so viel ausgeben kann. Man war gezwungen, Jacob Ramsey zu verkaufen, da kam nicht viel hinterher. Dann auch noch sehr schlecht gestartet, die ersten fünf Spiele ohne Sieg und ohne Tor. Und dann trotzdem jetzt Platz 3. Toller Teamspirit, super gecoacht. Morgan Rogers hat sich weiterentwickelt. Brandier nach der Leverkusenleihe blüht gerade wieder auf. Aber das ganz Interessante ist, wie sich Aston Villa jetzt neu erfunden hat in letzter Zeit. Wenn man sich mal die Expected Goals anguckt, da sieht man, dass Aston Villa in Sachen Expected Goals ziemlich weit hinten ist. Gleichzeitig steht man da relativ zurecht, zumindest relativ weit oben zurecht. Denn Aston Villa hat einen Weg gefunden, sich neu zu erfinden, weil Villa war immer bekannt dafür, immer sehr gut Räume zu attackieren unter MRE. Das ist auch wieder so typisch MRE-Fußball. Jetzt hatten sich die Gegner gerade zu Beginn der Saison darauf eingestellt, sehr tief gegen Villa gestanden und sie dadurch gezwungen, einfach kreative Lösungen vorne zu finden und aus wenig Raum viel zu machen. Damit hat sich Villa schwer. Seitdem hat Esten Villa angefangen, einfach mal sehr oft aus der Distanz zu schießen. Und das relativ erfolgreich. Denn keine Mannschaft der Premier League schießt so oft aus der Ferne und vor allem keine Mannschaft trifft so oft aus der Ferne, auch prozentual gesehen. Der Premier League-Schnitt für Distanztore ist bei 8 Prozent. Esten Villa ist bei 45 Prozent.
Ich habe eine Idee, warum das nicht nachhaltig sein wird. Genau, richtig.
Man muss dazu sagen, sie haben wirklich sehr viele Spieler mit einer sehr guten Schusstechnik. Das muss man dazu sagen. Morgan Rogers, Randy McGinn, Cash. Da sind auch viele Freistöße dabei und das machen sie wirklich herausragend gut. Sie haben auch wirklich die beste Conversion-Rate bei diesen Distanztchüssen. Das machen sie hervorragend. Aber wie du schon sagst, ich weiß nicht, wie lange das gut geht. Es ist auch wieder dieses typische Unai Emery-Phänomen, das seine Mannschaft aktuell gnadenlos überperformt. Sie sind 12 Punkte über Expected Points. Das ist schon heftig. In der Offensive fünf Tore mehr geschossen, als sie sollten. In der Defensive fünf weniger kassiert. Klar, man kann dazu sagen, gerade in der Defensive, wenn du einen Keeper wie Emy Martinez hast, dann kassierst du vielleicht auch weniger, als du solltest, weil er einfach ein sehr guter Shotstopper ist. Und wenn du auch vorne Qualität hast, dann schießt du vielleicht auch ein paar mehr Tore, als du solltest. Du hast es statistisch gesehen, aber du hast es bereits gesagt. Ich glaube nicht, dass das Ganze nachhaltig ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass das mit den Weitschüssen auch immer so gut gehen wird. Die Hoffnung liegt vielleicht auch darin, dass die Gegner sich jetzt wieder dadurch ein bisschen rauslocken lassen und dadurch Räume entstehen, wer weiß. Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass Estenbiller jetzt komplett einbrechen wird und das Ganze eine ganz große Regression geben wird, aber sie werden wahrscheinlich mit der Zeit wieder ein bisschen nach unten kippen und wieder irgendwie Top 4 kämpfen müssen. Und das wäre auch absolut in Ordnung, aber es ist trotzdem ganz interessant, wie sich Villa hier einen neuen Weg gefunden hat, sozusagen, wieder aus der Krise rauszukommen.
Kann es sein, dass Unai Emery hinter so großen Namen wie Guardiola, Arteta, Klopp vielleicht einer der besten Premier League-Trainer ist?
Ja, ich finde schon. Also auch nicht nur in England, sondern auch in Europa, wenn man sieht, was er auch in Spanien leistet zwischendurch. Ich finde aber auch, dass Unai Emery– und es soll keine Kritik an ihm sein– er funktioniert nicht bei den ganz großen Teams so gut. Ich glaube, ihm tut die Außenseiterrolle gut. Ich glaube, ihm tut die geringere Erwartungshaltung gut. Und auch im Stil seiner Mannschaften sieht man, dass sie nicht wie ein absolutes Top-Team auftreten. Und dass sie auch, sobald sie als solches behandelt werden, ein bisschen Probleme damit haben. Denn es ist kein Zufall, dass sie gerade gegen die Großen die besten Leistungen abspulen. Aber keine Frage, das soll jetzt nicht Maries Leistungen schmälern. Denn man sieht, der Mann hat Ahnung, er findet auch immer wieder Wege, nicht nur auf eine Art und Weise zu performen. Und scheint auch immer wieder es zu schaffen, einen absoluten Top-Team-Spirit in seiner Mannschaft zu schaffen. Und seine Mannschaften sind auch immer unfassbar gut, unfassbar diszipliniert und gut aufgestellt und organisiert. Und das ist natürlich die Arbeit eines Top-Trainer, das ist keine Frage.
Ja, stimmt. Und man kann natürlich auch noch ein bisschen was zu seinem Auftreten sagen. Ich glaube, Fabian hat da mal vor ein paar Jahren, haben wir da ja ein sehr launiges Segment in der Ligatur dazu gehabt. Da ging es unter anderem auch um Unai Emery. Aber hat es geschafft, eben ersten Villa nicht nur jetzt kurzfristig zu Erfolg zu führen, sondern sie sind jetzt auch wieder unofficial World-Club-Champion. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitverfolgt. Das ist eines meiner liebsten Hobbys, das mitzuverfolgen. Es geht quasi nach dem, sagen wir, nach dem Boxschema, beginnend beim allerersten aufgezeichneten Fußballspiel. Immer der jeweilige, der, der den aktuellen Titelträger besiegt, der ist neuer Club World Champion. Und ersten Villa ist da Rekordtitelträger, aber hat jetzt zum ersten Mal seit, ich glaube, den 60ern, wieder diesen Titel geholt mit dem Sieg gegen Arsenal. Ach, das ist, das ist schön. Es waren schlimme Zeiten, als dieser Titel in der 2. Französischen Liga verbuddelt war, auf Jahrzehnte hin, bevor er wieder dann irgendwie nach oben kam. Wir fliegen noch einmal kurz über die Themen.
Wer war das in der Bundesliga damals? War das da St. Pauli, Weltpokalsieger, Besieger? Oder wie war das?
Ja gut, aber das war ja nur ein Marketing-Ding. Also ja, klar, sie haben nicht…
Das war ja wirklich nur ausgedacht.
Ja, genau. Aber hallo, der anöphische Klappe. Du musst mal auf die Seite von dir gehen. Sieht aus wie von 1980 allein. Das macht alles daran schon mal sympathisch. Also wer auf fbref.com geht und sagt, boah, hier ist es aber hübsch. Für euch ist auch diese andere Seite gemacht. Es ist einfach wirklich fantastisch. Ich werde es verlinken in den Show-Nutz. Das ist wirklich eine herrliche Spielerei. Leverkusen hatte den Titel lange, Bayern hatte den Titel lange. Und jetzt eben dann über Arsenal ist er jetzt zu VIA gekommen. Und es gab eben ganz lange– Borussia Dortmund war Titelträger. Und dann haben sie– gegen welches prassianische Team haben sie gespielt? Auf jeden Fall die haben damals so sehr gehofft, dass sie bei der Club-WM verlieren, dass dieser Titel mal den Kontinent wechselt. Das ist dann allerdings nicht so passiert. Aber gut, ich verlinke es in den Show-Nutz. Es ist wirklich eine wunderbare Spielerei. Sonnys, du hast vorhin schon mal kurz angedeutelt, es gibt da ein bisschen Terminkaus in der spanischen Liga. Christian hat auch schon mit eingestimmt in Italien offenbar auch. Was ist denn da so schlimm? Was kann denn da so schlimm sein?
Spanische Verhältnisse und Termine, wo irgendwie auch mal zwei Wochen vorher noch ein Ligaspiel verändert wird. Jetzt ist Copa del Rey, das ist schon immer noch im Herbst, im Winter angesagt. Aber jetzt kommt es auch in der nächsten Woche noch zum 16. Finale. Und da greifen ja dann auch diese vier Super-Copa-Teams ein. Die sind sonst um den 10. Januar herum in Saudi-Arabien natürlich im Einsatz, um da den Superpokal auszutragen. Normal war vorher da immer das 16. Finale. Und jetzt kam es ein bisschen zu diesem Terminkaus, was auch gar nicht alle auf dem Schirm hatten, dass jetzt überhaupt diese Runde jetzt noch ausgetragen wurde im La-Liga-Spielplan, Kalender war das auch nicht eingetragen. Die letzten Spiele der zweiten Runde wurden am 4. Dezember letzte Woche ausgetragen. Da hat man sich so gedacht, ja gut, dann werden jetzt schon die nächsten Spiele, 16. Finale, dann am 16. Dezember beginnen. Man hätte ja schön 11 Tage Zeitvorbereitung dazwischen. Auslosung wird dann bestimmt am 5. Dezember dann gemacht. Wurde nicht gemacht. Wurde auch nicht wie bei der DFL dann am Wochenende nach einem Spiel vielleicht gemacht. Auch nicht am Montag danach. Also es war jetzt erst am 9. Dezember die Auslosung. Sprich dann an Clubs und Medien und Fans nur 7 Tage Zeit, sich auf die Spiele vorzubereiten. Das zeigt mal wieder so ein bisschen diese ganze Termin, die Kurzfristigkeit, die, oh, der muss schon planen können, was in Spanien, was mich auch schon regelmäßig stört. Aber da, wie gesagt, jetzt am 16. Dezember beginnt die dritte Runde in der Copa de Rey dann auch mit den vier Supercopa-Teams. Real Madrid ist bei Talavera und da geht es dann rund, ehe dann Mitte Januar oder 10. Januar um, dann die Supercopa wieder angesagt ist. Real Madrid gegen Atletico und Barca gegen den Athletic Club sind dann Saudi-Arabien, die Spiele. Aber ich wollte mal wieder euch zeigen, ich glaube, DFB-Pokal war jetzt direkt nach den Spielen an einem Wochenende die Auslosung auch für dann Spiele in zwei, drei Monaten, wo alles ein bisschen langfristig ist. Von dem her, das wünsche ich mir manchmal nicht spanische Verhältnisse in Deutschland, sondern eher deutsche Verhältnisse in Spanien. Aber gut, hier wird halt die Copa de Rey gefühlt in zwei, drei Monaten reingepresst und wenn dann nicht mal, dann hättest du mal Zeit, wie gesagt, gehabt, Auslosung früh zu machen, 11 Tage Vorbereitung. Nö, wir haben ja noch Zeit. Mach mal am Dienstag, damit es dann nur 7 Tage Vorbereitung sind. Naja.
Aber findet denn dann diese Auslosung wenigstens auch im spanischen Pendant des Sportstudios oder der Sportschaustadt mit irgendwelchen Amateur-Club-Vertretern dahinter, die gezwungen werden, Schilder hochzuhalten und zu jubeln, wenn sie Rhabar Leipzig gezogen bekommen?
Ja, im Sportstudio jetzt nicht, aber ja, es gibt dann Live-Schalten zu. Es waren, glaube ich, 4 Drittligisten und ein Viertligist mit Atletico Baleares noch dabei. Und natürlich gibt es da dann die Live-Schalten rein. Da muss auch der Kapitän immer noch sagen, ja, wir freuen uns, es ist ein schwieriges Los, aber wir sind als Team gut drauf und wir freuen uns. Also ja, ein paar Emotionen sind dabei, wenn sich da jemand freut, der dann Real Madrid oder Barca zugelost bekommt. Und wenn es ein Atletico ist, euer Auge.
Ja, stark. Aber genau das will ich sehen. Ich liebe es– es tut mir leid, das ist jetzt sehr masochistisch– aber ich liebe es, genau in die Blicke von Vereinsvertretern von so Amateurclubs zu gucken, wenn sie dann Leverkusen ziehen. Oder, ja gut, ich will es gar nicht mit allen Bundesligisten verscherzen, aber ihr wisst genau, welche Fälle ich meine, auf wen sie hoffen und wen sie dann bekommen. Und dann siehst du, wie sie sich im Gedankenöffnung denken, na toll, wir wären ja eh ausgeschieden, hätten wir nicht gegen Bayern ausscheiden können. Oder dort?
Ja, so ungefähr.
Spanisch halt.
Na gut.
Spanische Verhältnisse. Ich weiß nicht, was Rahmenterminkalender auf Spanisch bedeutet, aber vielleicht bräuchte es den mal an der Stelle. Bernie, ist das ein Thema in Italien auch? Willst du dazu auch noch was sagen? Oder magst du uns ein anderes, weiteres Thema mitbringen? Weil du es vorhin nur so angedeutet hast.
Also, nee, so extrem nehme ich es in Italien nicht wahr. Ich wollte nur wegen dieser Supercoppa. Die ist ja in Italien normalerweise auch, war es die letzten Jahre immer Anfang Januar, ähnlich wie die Spanier eben. Und dieses Jahr ist es jetzt plötzlich eben die Woche vor Weihnachten. Das heißt, Napoli, Milan, Inter und Bologna reisen da dann auch für ein paar Tage wieder in den Nahen Osten. Das heißt, deren Ligaspiele müssen da logischerweise verschoben werden. Und ja, genau deswegen ist immer dieses Thema Supercoppa halt eines, das da rund um den Jahreswechsel, ja, das die meisten anderen Ligen jetzt ja so nicht kennen, dass mitten in der Saison dann plötzlich nur die Supercoppa reinschneit, sozusagen. Das wollte ich eigentlich damit sagen. Aber noch ein Satz, nur ganz letzter. Ihr könnt euch erinnern, wir hatten ja das Milan gegen Cormor Spiel, womöglich in Perth in Australien. Das ist jetzt auch kurz vor der Absage. Also wir hatten ja damals, ich glaube, ich habe es ja gesagt, fand ich ja gut, dass da die spanische Nummer in Miami sozusagen nicht geklappt hat und die italienische Nummer jetzt in Australien, so wie es jetzt dieser Tage aussieht, wird auch nicht klappen. Das ist ja vielleicht mal ein kleines, schönes Zeichen.
Aber warum? Also…
Ja, das ist auch sehr tiefschichtig. Angeblich reden da dann auch der asiatische Fußballverband will da mitreden und der australische. Und die haben anscheinend ein paar Forderungen gestellt, dass dann irgendwann die italienische Liga sagt wird, nö, so dann auch nicht. Also es ging jetzt nicht nur darum, dass eben sozusagen dieser Fan-Protest da das einzige auslösende Signal war. Max, du hast es ja, glaube ich, auch gesagt, es gab ja auch mal Fragezeichen von den Veranstaltern, ob das denn überhaupt wirtschaftlich so sinnvoll ist. Aber ich finde, man kann zumindest am Ende sagen, da hatte die spanische und italienische Liga eine Idee, die sehr viele nicht gut fanden. Und am Ende gehen die zwei Nähen jetzt anscheinend auch nicht auf. Dann würde ich sagen, kann man das ja auch mal, auch wenn verschiedene Gründe mit reinspielen, ja schon durchaus auch mal als positiven, wie soll man sagen, Response lernen. Oder seht ihr das anders?
Das spanische Spiel ist auch mehr abgesagt worden von Seiten des Veranstaltes, dass er den Gegenwind gespürt hat. La Liga hätte das schon noch durchgeprügelt, aber auch da war lange Überlegung, wie wirtschaftlich ist das, wenn dann teilweise den Fans von Villarreal auch die Reise gezahlt werden soll. Und da kommt ja auch einiges zusammen. Und was soll der ganze Aufwand, der ganze Quatsch? Ich fand den Protest der Spieler gar nicht so stark. Und wir hatten auch darüber geredet, La Liga hat es teilweise zensiert und es waren irgendwie ziemlich unterschiedlich. Egal, aber wurde gestrichen. Das ist gut, aber La Liga hätte das schon durchgeprügelt. Und Javier Tebas wird in nächstes Jahr, in zwei Jahren, das wieder versuchen. Das ist sein großer Traum.
Ja, nicht falsch verstehen.
Das wird jetzt immer weiter wieder probiert werden.
Klar. Also die italienische Serie A hätte das logisch auch ganz gerne gemacht. Also gar keine Frage. Also ich wollte jetzt nicht Dienstschutz nehmen. Ich sage nur, das wurde einfach dahin geknallt. Und die haben vielleicht gedacht, das geht einfach durch. Aber aus unterschiedlichen Gründen ist es jetzt ja doch zweimal nicht durchgegangen. Ist ja vielleicht nicht die schlechteste Entwicklung.
Ja, so haben wir halt dann nur irgendwelche Superkoppers im Nahen Osten.
Gott sei Dank sind die moderner Fußball.
Wollen wir jetzt nicht drüber reden.
Ja, aber ich hätte euch gerne noch ganz kurz eine schöne, positive Geschichte mitgebracht, nämlich Genua, FC Genua. Die haben auch vor rund eineinhalb Monaten Trainer entlassen, nämlich Patrick Vera. Die waren bis zu dem Zeitpunkt auch noch sieglos. Also da lief es alles andere als gut. Und übernommen hat Daniele De Rossi, ehemaliger Roma-Legende und auch ehemaliger Roma-Trainer, der ja seit diesem komischen Ende bei der Roma jetzt erst mal sich das Ganze von außen angesehen hat. Ja, und seit De Rossi da ist, muss man sagen, das erste Spiel war noch unter einem Interimstrainer. Da war er zwar schon verkündet, aber saß noch nicht auf der Bank. Aber seitdem fünf Spiele und in der Tabelle der letzten fünf Spiele steht Genua auf Platz 3 in der Serie A. Also nur Milan und Inter haben mehr Punkte geholt. Gena hat jetzt 11 Punkte geholt, also mehr als Napoli, mehr als Juve, mehr als Roma. Und hat das mit einem sehr spektakulären Stil. Sie haben in jedem Spiel mindestens zwei Tore geschossen. Also sie kreieren viel. De Rossi hat da irgendwie gleich eine spielerische Note irgendwie mit reinbekommen. Die Stürmer haben so ein bisschen, das war Anfang der Saison, die haben alle nicht getroffen. Und jetzt siehst du gerade bei den Offensiven, da ist Selbstvertrauen da, haben jetzt Udinese geschlagen, haben drei Siege eingefahren, sind ungeschlagen. Es ist wieder dieses Januar, das auch in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren, ja auch unter WRA, eben immer wieder für positive Randgeschichten gesorgt hat. Und ich wollte euch nur einen Spieler mitbringen, schauen ob der Chris dazu, ob er den auf dem Schirm hat. Brooke Norton-Cuffey, U21-Nationalspieler, Englischer, stammt aus der Arsenaljugend, war im Sommer U21-Europameister, auch mit England. Und der spielt da eben in diesem 3-5-2 auf der rechten Schiene, hat jetzt gegen Udinese sein erster Saison-Tor erzählt. Und der Rossi, und ich muss sagen, auf die Einschätzungen von der Rossi verlasse ich mich. Der junge Mann weiß gar nicht, was für ein riesiges Potenzial er hat. Er hat das Potenzial, einer der besten auf dieser Position zu werden, auch international, extreme Athletik, extreme Physis. Das müssen wir jetzt alles nur ein bisschen kanalisieren. Aber das Junge, der sehr gut zuhört, der viel aufpasst, der wissbegierig ist, ist ein Jahrgang 2004er. Also vielleicht von dem hören wir in Zukunft auch noch deutlich mehr. Ich glaube, der ist jetzt bei der Rossi in guten Händen.
Hm, Brook Norton-Coffee merken wir uns.
Rechtsverteidiger. Sorry, ich habe extra nachgeschaut. Hat auch eben U21-EM-Finale gegen Deutschland. Da kam er rein, hat nicht von Anfang gespielt, aber hat, glaube ich, mit Verlängerung auch noch eine Stunde oder so gespielt, kam Anfang zweiter Hälfte rein. Also ist er, wie gesagt, schon im Teil, italienisch, sorry, der Englische U21. Und also der Rossi hat den wirklich extrem hervorgehoben, hat gemeint, er hat alles das, was so ein Gasperini aussen diese, was ich sage mal, die Schule, Bela Norver, Goossens, Hartebua, die als diese Schienenspieler auch wirklich Offensive generiert haben. Und er hat gemeint, der ist in der Spur. Und wenn wir da fleißig weiterarbeiten, dann kriegen wir den auf ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr hohes Niveau.
Da sollte man hellhörig werden. Das wäre doch einer für einen BVB zum Beispiel. Aber gut, das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema. Chris, wenn du magst, wenn du was zu Brooklyn Norton-Coffee noch sagen willst, dann werde es los. Wobei, wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe, England hat jetzt nicht so wirklich seine Fußstapfe hinterlassen, jenseits vom UNationalteam, muss man ehrlicherweise dazu sagen. Aber was hast du uns denn noch mitgebracht?
Ich habe uns Ryan Scherke mitgebracht. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das Tor gesehen habt, beziehungsweise die Vorlage am Wochenende beim 13.0 von Manchester City gegen Sunderland. Rabona-Vorlage, also wirklich nicht nur so ein unnötiges Ding, was man auch öfter mal sieht, sondern wirklich perfekt eingesetzt, perfekt ausgeführt, also wirklich eine traumhafte Vorlage. Da war auch Man of the Match bei dem Spiel, zwei Vorlagen geliefert. Ja, ziemlich interessant. Scherke blüht momentan auf, ist so ein Freigeist in der Offensive, der auch mal solche Kunststückchen wagt. Und wer Pep Guardiola kennt, so was mag er eigentlich gar nicht so sehr, wenn man an Jack Greedish denkt oder an weitere Spieler. Denn Guardiola ist natürlich immer sehr auf Ordnung, Struktur, Disziplin aus. Und war auch ganz witzig nach dem Spiel, hat er natürlich diese besondere und einzigartige Qualität Scherkis gelobt. Gleichzeitig natürlich auch ein bisschen Kritik drin versteckt. Anders geht es nicht. Er hat gesagt, wenn er das macht und es klappt nicht, dann mag ich das nicht. Ich habe Messi so was nie machen sehen. Messi macht die simplen Dinge perfekt. Und war ganz interessant, dass er das erwähnte.
Also er hat quasi gesagt, ich finde ihn doof, weil er ist nicht Messi. Toll.
So könnte man es nicht sagen. Ich fand es aber ganz interessant, weil er gleichzeitig indirekt diesen Messi-Vergleich wählte. Also nicht direkt einen Vergleich, sondern weil er die Messlatte so hochlegte und vielleicht Scherky damit sagen wollte, du, du hast dieses Potenzial, mach die simplen Dinge.
Nicht nur das, er hat sogar die Messi-Latte hochgelegt.
Ja, so ist es.
Und Scherky selbst sagte danach selbst über sich, dass er so eine Art Freigeist ist und dass es einfach sein Spiel ist. Und ja, also man merkt, es ist nicht der typische Pep-Spieler, aber es tut Main City unglaublich gut momentan, diese Kreativität, diese Überraschungsmomente. Denn man hat da ein bisschen mit dem Abgang von de Bruyne und auch mit als de Bruyne älter wurde so ein bisschen diese Elemente im Spiel verloren. Und die Offensive war auch sehr, sehr Haarlandlastig. Und jetzt kommt da so ein bisschen mehr Kreativität rein. Und ich glaube, an Scherky wird City und die Premier League noch sehr viel Spaß haben.
Und es ist eigentlich auch interessant, dass Pep Guardiola da noch so bremst. Denn eigentlich, also wenn er irgendwo ein Auge zudrückt, dann vorne im Angriffstrittel. Also wenn man sich mit seinem Fußball beschäftigt, klar, Positionsspiel und so weiter und so fort. Aber wenn es Freiheiten gibt, dann eben im Angriffstrittel. Und da ist es eigentlich auch in Ordnung mal was Unvorhergesehenes zu tun. Es muss halt vielleicht nicht mit Kunststücken sein. Das verstehe ich schon, dass da Pep Guardiola kritisch ist. Aber ja, also ich finde auch, dass auch diese Kombination mit Haaland, finde ich, passt total gut, weil wir alle, also Erling Haaland spielt eine wahnsinnige Saison. Irre, wie gut er aktuell drauf ist. Und dann jemanden zu haben, der aus nichts alles machen kann. Und Haaland vollendet dann, ja, also, könnte noch mal eng werden in der Premier League.
Ja, vor allem, weil Phil Foden auch wieder so ein bisschen zu alter Stärke findet aktuell. Also die Offensive, die findet sich gerade bei City. Und das ist natürlich, ja, so ein schönes Ausrufezeichen von City an die Konkurrenz.
Aber wirklich, 35 Tore jetzt nach 15 Spielen und damit Rang 1 in dieser Kategorie in der Liga. Jetzt schauen wir nochmal nach Frankreich. Ein letztes Mal, Jakob, du darfst quasi die Ligatour heute zuschließen. Was hast du uns mitgebracht?
Eine Trainerentlassung und zwar die zweite in dieser Saison von gestern Abend. Also noch backfrisch könnte man auch sagen. Aus Nantes kommt diese Trainerentlassung. Da waren erst die Töne nach dem Wochenende, dass Luis Castro wohl noch im Amt bleiben darf. Dann hat er auch gestern Vormittag noch die Spieltagspressekonferenz für das Wochenende absolviert und wurde dann aber nachmittags oder am frühen Abend doch entlassen. Also eine etwas kuriose Situation. Ich meine, dass es das ja bei Graeme Potter und West Ham auch gab in dieser Saison, dass er die Spieltagspressekonferenz noch gemacht hat und dann entlassen wurde. Aber ja, ist jetzt vielleicht so nicht der allerbeste Umgang. Aber gut, so ist es nun mal gewesen. Luis Castro war auch erst seit Sommer bei Nantes, aber es lief jetzt wirklich eigentlich die ganze Saison über nicht gut. Man hat erst zweimal gewonnen, ist vorletzter Punkt gleich mit dem letzten Mess. Also steht da mit 11 Punkten aus 15 Spielen auch wirklich nicht gut da. Allerdings muss man ein bisschen zur Verteidigung von Luis Castro auch sagen, dass ich auch finde, dass im Sommer ziemlich vieles ja vielleicht nicht unbedingt kaputt gemacht wurde, aber er auch nicht vor den leichtesten Umbruch gestellt wurde. Also ihm wurde wohl auch schon beim Antritt gesagt, dass die Abgänge, die es geben wird, nicht so richtig ersetzt werden sollen, bzw. wenn dann mit günstigen Spielern oder halt mit Spielern aus der eigenen Jugend. Und es sind aber im Sommer mal eben sechs der elf am meisten eingesetzten Spieler weggegangen, darunter drei Innenverteidiger, die eigentlich die Stamminnenverteidigung gebildet haben und die beiden, die immer im zentralen Mittelfeld zusammengespielt haben. Also Pedro Chirivella z.B., der ja früher auch mal bei Liverpool war, ist gegangen in der Innenverteidigung mit Nathan Cece, auch einer, der für über 20 Millionen, glaube ich, nach Saudi-Arabien gewechselt ist. Ein großes Innenverteidiger-Talent eigentlich. Mit Nicolas Palois, ein sehr alter Routinier, der aber trotzdem noch seine Leistung meistens gebracht hat, also auch ein Führungsspieler innerhalb der Mannschaft. Und mit Moses Simon auch eigentlich der Spieler, der in der Offensive jetzt in den letzten Jahren und meistens dann vor dem Abstieg gerettet hat. Man war ja auch in der letzten Saison am Ende nur knapp überm Strich, war also auch eigentlich die ganze Saison in den Abstiegskampf verwickelt, diese Entwicklung, dass es jetzt nicht unbedingt besser läuft, wenn man die besten Spieler abgibt, kommt nicht so richtig überraschend. Luis Castro wirkte allerdings auch ein bisschen hilflos da, wirklich gegen zu arbeiten. Also er hat eigentlich immer an seinem 4-3-3 festgehalten. Sehr hohe Abseits-Linie, also wirklich extrem hoch für ein Team, was eher um den Abstieg spielt und irgendwie hat nicht so richtig funktioniert. Die Offensive ist nicht gut, die Defensive ist nicht gut. Man hat auch nach Expected Points die schlechteste Bilanz in der Liga. In der Offensive hängt eigentlich alles an Matisse Ablin, der wirklich ein herausragender Spieler auch ist, er ist 22. Der trifft allerdings auch in dieser Saison nicht so richtig gut, ist aber trotzdem mit Abstand der beste Offensivspieler noch, wollte im Sommer eigentlich auch schon weg. Da wollte Nond aber wohl sehr viel Geld für ihn haben und hat ihn dann noch nicht ziehen lassen. Also es ist jetzt auch nicht so richtig überraschend, alles was in Nond passiert. Mal gucken, ob jetzt der neue Mann an der Seitenlinie, das ist Ahmed Kantari, der war in der letzten Saison auch Co-Trainer bei Nond, unter Antoine Cumbert, hat jetzt eigentlich gar keine Erfahrung als Cheftrainer, außer mal kurz bei Valenciennes und ist auch mit 40 jetzt noch sehr jung. Soll aber bis Sommer bleiben, also ist jetzt nicht nur eine Interims-Lösung, sondern soll tatsächlich dann auch Nond vor dem Abstieg retten. Ist jetzt, glaube ich, nichts, was einen von außen wirklich darauf hoffen lässt, dass da die große Trendwende kommt. Aber ich meine, ich habe ja in Deutschland auch einen Verein, den ich unterstütze. Bei dem hat ja auch die Beförderung eines jungen Co-Trainers Wunder bewirkt. Mal gucken. Aber schauen wir mal, wie sich das jetzt bei Amit Khandhari entwickelt. Kann ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel zu sagen. Es gab auch erst die Gerüchte, ob vielleicht Will Still wieder übernimmt, der ja auch bei Nond mal war und ja jetzt auch gerade keinen Job mehr hat. Allerdings wurde das auch nicht durchgesetzt. Jetzt macht es halt einen ganz unerfahrener.
Aber immerhin hat man sich da mal festgelegt. Also man hat lange gebraucht für die Entscheidung, aber dann hat man sich immerhin committed, wie man Neudeutsch sagt. Ja, ihr vier, herzlichen Dank. Das war mal wieder ein wilder Ritt durch alle möglichen Themen. Ich habe auch viel eurer Zeit beansprucht. Deswegen ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank, Jakob Havke, Chris McCarthy, Nils Kern und Christian Bernhardt. Danke euch für eure Zeit. Und dann habe ich noch eine leichte Latenz zwischen aufgebaut. Und dann habe ich auch noch einen Podcast Tipp für euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und zwar, ich glaube, wenn ihr diese Ligatur hier gehört und gemocht habt, dann wird euch wahrscheinlich auch das Tribüngespräch gefallen, das ich aufgenommen habe mit Jürgen Kalver. Wir haben anlässlich des MLS-Finals zwischen Lionel Messi und Thomas Müller, ich will euch nicht verraten, wer gewonnen hat, haben wir darüber gesprochen, wie eigentlich die Geschichte des Fußballs in den USA ist, wie hat sich Fußball dort etabliert und warum hat es eigentlich mehrere Anläufe gebraucht, die Liga zu etablieren und letztlich auch die Frage, ist sie denn jetzt eigentlich etabliert, nur weil Lionel Messi da spielt und auch Thomas Müller dorthin gewechselt ist. Es ist ein sehr langes Gespräch geworden, so wie ihr es vom Rasenfunk gewohnt seid. Bisher ist das Feedback darauf sehr, sehr gut und deswegen könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass euch diese Folge auch gefällt. Ich werde sie in den Show Notes verlinken und ansonsten danke ich euch natürlich auch für eure finanzielle Unterstützung. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Don Garellos, bei Greenback First, bei Der Pater, bei Abwehr Alex und bei Nur wegen der Ibern hier. Danke für euren finanziellen Support, denn ihr wisst ja, alles hier im Rasenfunk ist nur von euch finanziert. Keine Werbung, keine Sponsoren, keine Paywall, weil wir alles drei doof finden. In diesem Sinne, auf rasenfunk.de gibt es alle Informationen, wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt und ansonsten freue ich mich, wenn ihr uns gewogen bleibt. Bis bald, ciao! Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!